it's earth day and because we've been
honoring this beautiful planet
throughout the show we need some easy
ways that we can all be greener in our
homes year round and so we turn to our
resident green guru and dear friend of
the show editor-in-chief of naturally
danny ceo danny seahouse hi happy
birthday
yay
take it away you're in the driver's seat
what are we doing okay so tip number one
for earth day guys if you feel
overwhelmed i always say do just one
thing
so get rid of those dryer sheets first
and foremost you don't need them they're
absolutely obsolete they're not
biodegradable they're made out of
plastics and things so they don't
degrade in the landfill and you don't
need it okay this is the alternative
these are wool dryer balls guys you can
buy these they're reusable almost
forever in your dryer what they do is
they go in your jar and they fluff
everything around so you're using about
50 percent less electricity to dry
everything which means your clothes your
towels everything also dries more
quickly you can add a little essential
oil on the inside to scent everything
which is super nice oh i've never done
that and they also get rid of static
because they absorb humidity in the
beginning and then release the excess
moisture throughout the drying cycle to
get all the wrinkles out they're
incredible you guys i'm really
wait dude do you think some people need
these should we you guys want some are
you guys ready i got your arm
[Applause]
happy earth day
[Applause]
what's next nutshell
so if you have pistachios or whatever
kind of nuts that you love save the
shells guys you can use these for so
many different things first and foremost
if the nuts are salted you want to soak
them in water for a couple of hours to
get rid of the residual salt because
what we're going to do is here i think
we have some gloves if you want to use
them or just use your hands doesn't
matter
but you're going to take in your potted
plants at home you're gonna fill the
bottom
of your uh potted plants with some
nutshells
and what this does it helps with
drainage and over time it actually
degrades into a beneficial mulch for
your plants really so you don't you
don't put them in the landscape have
some potted plants and i've actually
resorted to putting like little plates
underneath them because we've all gotten
that ring
and then you like over water and then it
just
what's next okay we're gonna talk about
pollinators guys you know we have to
support bees we have to support
butterflies but did you know that when
you're planting flowers in your garden
the best choice for pollinators are blue
periwinkle these shades like in cone
flowers corn flowers hydrangeas they
love this because blue flowers have the
highest amount of nectar
so they're naturally attracted to blue
flowers so if you can plant as many blue
flowers as possible not only are they
gonna love your yard they're also gonna
make sure your fruit trees your flowers
the vegetables you're going all get
pollinated and you'll have the best yard
in the block so on our
celebration of all things green we
should plant all things blue exactly
okay i like that i like that oh my gosh
that's so amazing go green let's go blue
um we have teamed up with an amazing
company called inspire clean energy for
this segment and danny i would love for
you to tell us about it well i'm
obsessed with them because it's so
important to reduce your carbon
footprint with 20 of uh carbon emissions
coming from home energy use here in the
united states so one of the biggest
steps you can take to live more
sustainably and create a positive impact
on the planet guys is by accessing clean
energy for your home which means energy
from renewable sources like wind and
solar power so inspire is a clean energy
company that matches the dirty energy
your home runs on with clean renewable
energy without any interruptions to your
service
no installations either it's all digital
all you do is sign up online and with a
clean energy plan like inspires your
environmental impact for one year just
one year can have greater impact than
years of recycling oh my god and you
just go online and you're done
like
i love when technology is good for the
planet i love when it's easy i love this
so much and if you guys would like to
help create a greener future for our
planet today from the comfort of your
home please make sure that you check out
inspirecleanenergy.com and sign up today
so let's all do it together as a group
effort
love it
game time baby
[Music]